son niñas y están en un hospital en sus
cuerpos veneno ataques registrados en
más de 50 escuelas en al menos 21 de las
31 provincias de Irán era la clase de
Educación Física cuando fuimos al
pasillo olimos algo parecido a un
perfume tengo un entumecimiento muy
Severo en mi cuerpo no puedo caminar en
absoluto todas las estudiantes sintieron
los mismos síntomas que yo tenían todos
algunas dijeron que les ardían los ojos
y la mayoría estaban asustadas los
envenenamientos comenzaron en noviembre
en la ciudad Santa musulmana para los
chiítas de quam pero hasta hace unos
días no se anunció una investigación
Este es el último comunicado difundido
por el Ministerio del interior
la seguridad de los estudiantes es la
principal prioridad de los funcionarios
síntomas observados en 52 escuelas hasta
ahora la mayoría de las personas son
dadas de alta después de recibir
atención ambulatoria Ministerio de salud
anunciará los resultados de la
investigación pericial intentos del
enemigo de forzar el cierre de los
centros educativos
este último punto es al que dirigen los
focos los políticos iraníes
Por supuesto que a nuestros enemigos les
gusta causar disturbios en el país a
través de operaciones y ahora están
apareciendo una vez más para jugar con
las emociones del pueblo iraní e incitar
al miedo
pero otros señalamientos indican que
detrás estarían grupos radicales
religiosos que se oponen a la educación
de las niñas derecho que no había sido
puesto en duda en más de 40 años de
revolución islámica sin embargo esto ha
cambiado tras las protestas más grandes
en décadas con gran protagonismo de
estudiantes y que dejan al menos 5 30
personas muertas y la detención de
alrededor de 20.000 personas según Human
Rights Active